The people of Colombia who voted against the
agreement with the Revolutionary Armed Forces
of Colombia, known by the Spanish initials
FARC, aren't rejecting peace and favoring
war.
The government of Juan Manuel Santos negotiated
with the terrorists for four years in Cuba
and came up with a series of agreements where
they would lay down their arms, they would
be gradually reintegrated into society.
The Colombian people considered the details
of the plan.
The fact that the guerillas would submit themselves
to some sort of ad hoc tribunals rather than
the normal judicial system.
They would be accorded seats almost immediately
in the Colombian Congress.
And so, you had people who were considering
all of the damage done.
The murders, the killing, the mayhem meted
out by the FARC.
And now, these people are going to find their
way into the congress instead of going to
jail.
So now, we go back to the drawing board and
to negotiate new terms by which the guerillas
will lay down their arms and be reintegrated
in Colombian society.
Do you think Colombians made the right call
in rejecting this peace deal?
Let us know in the comments section, and let
us know what other topics you want AEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds.